[Applaudissements]
ça a été magique
en direct un festival concrètement je
fermais milliard et les gens sont
humides
vous savez que l'on tombé là et savoir
[Applaudissements]
mettez un secteur une soulte et les ados
[Musique]
de morgen lourd
notre copain anthony cayla qui mise
après cette sagesse et de la ctu promet
m6 ayant repéré le talent on s'est dit
on ne peut pas se contenter de lui
donner ça on va taper très fort c'est le
retour de votre émission fétiche samedi
18h30 du trésor dans votre maison
revient six des 18 heures sur m6 elle
soupire solutions souvent copié rarement
égalé allez on va jouer si vous le
voulez bien à lui moi si tu peux pour
donc rendre hommage à ce jeu que j'avais
proposée au tout début c'est vrai c'est
un peu fort mais c'est bien pour ici
c'est pas le principe est simple je vais
vous proposer à tous des types de
personnes si jamais ce type de personne
vous séduit vous ne faites rien la
lumière restera allumée sur vous si ça
ne vous séduit pas on éteindra la
lumière qui est sûr alors attention on y
va voici la première affirmation est ce
que une personne à l'hygiène douteuse
s'avoue séduit ou scène nous séduit pas
les lumières vont s'activer et il ya que
jérôme anthony hémond combien ont quand
même connu s'assied que
france et on s'est lancé dans un truc
technique un peu au dessus de nos moyens
mais samedi ça tombe sur nous ça
voudrait dire si l'on en croit donc la
magie depuis ce que vous avez donné les
réponses avant évidemment sinon on
n'aurait pas pu allumer que vous auriez
dit à la production vous aimez les
personnes d'origine douteuse vous les
préférez propres je ne réponds pas c'est
pas les roms c'est un piège non j'aime
pas trop ça d'accord alors deuxième
question une personne très très radine
ah non voyons ce que vous avez donné
comme réponse à thème les radars alors
bah moi moi oui s'il est sympa et qui
les deux enfants adorent y en a
tellement
je n'avais pas du goût des frères appiah
hockey qui faisait que je te sens c'est
à dire ils payaient pas au restaurant
par exemple non il vous l'a fait ça n'a
pas trop de cadeaux pas d'offre à deux
restos est ce que cette discipline est
ce qui vous a déjà fait cette réplique
cultissime de mon copain franck dubosc
au restaurant au moment de payer la note
s'il te plaît justin au partage
[Rires]